[Musica]
dopo che al mercato mio padre comprò
ragazze venuto questo video sono valigie
regis un videogame stupendo perché prima
nel menu dei videogiochi in genere c'è
scritto nuova partita carica partita
uscita in alto in genere c'è il titolo
del gioco che c'è scritto sto gran
calcio di gioco che bel titolo c'è
proprio messi che si veste si vede che
avevamo scritto su una foglia e quindi
non non c'è scritto non si vede però c'è
lunghi ragazzi solo su video gay che si
chiama strangers stranieri praticamente
ragazzi credo sia un organo con po
strana però si va a papà partito proprio
così ero stanco di questa città ho preso
la mia macchina
grazie monte grande perfetto l'ho capito
tutto flavia è stava qua al titolo per
fa vedi che uscito dalla foglia nonché
ragazzi che non l'ho letto una mazza ma
credo di intuire che la trama si sa che
sto ragazzo ne ha deciso di prendersi
una casa e allora ha detto perché non
andiamo ad abitare in campagna che c'è
la fibra ottica ma la borsa della
palestra col con le mutande sudate
fantastico sembra che la gallina dei
vicini sia con sia scappata via
ma è morta una roba di definta a non è
finta che bella villa è la gallina piena
hd che io abbia mai visto che ragazzi
credo che appunto la trama si sa che lui
si è andato ad abitare da soli in questa
casa sperduta nei boschi e inter ha
scritto leggi e tu e di stress nel tuo
di stress che cazzo hai hunger games nel
nostro distretto ai ladri ladri sono in
cerca di prede hanno derubato le le case
di james e peter fai attenzione rob
grazie rob è praticamente voglio capire
la casa è molto fredda ho bisogno di
accendere il focolare accendiamo il
fuoco è proprio una ca dov'è il
climatizzatore quello nuovo della sony
che una telecamera ho bisogno sì sì
adesso prendiamo la legna per questo è
la latte di mucca geneticamente
modificata perché c'é del latte sul
tavolo che perché bello sfondo
fantastico ragazzi devo ancora capire
c'è un ascia posso difendermi dai ladri
bastardi che vi vengono a prendere tanto
devo prendere la legna quindi ok mi
piace ai poteri magici tipo harry potter
bene wingardium leviosa grande perfetto
ho preso la legna ragazzi
tornare un attimo accendere il fuoco
perché minchia perfetto devo cercare i
miei vestiti al piano di sopra si si pro
che ben corridoi arredato ragazzi bravo
pienoni quadri non c'è manco telefono la
porta è chiusa bisogno di una chiave a
casa tua
vorrei vedere come le chiavi permesso
aver letto c'è il letto e sono passi
avanti ragazzi viene a chi anche cazzola
presta chiave un transformer ragazzi
apriamo un'altra porta che ho bisogno di
avergli che c'è computer possiamo
guardarci poi il video di faringei
perfetto lo schifa vj start watching cam
uno show le camere fiat brava fantastico
quindi io posso vedere con le telecamere
le cose fantastico ma guarda quante
calmo il mare oggi confermo marca vacca
che grafica youtube ed si dà e vai a
dormire ragazzi ci siano e la notte
arrivano quando ho sentito un rumore al
rumoroso di fuori era molto buio e si ma
[ __ ] che si combatte c'è qualcosa
a terra ragazzi dobbiamo uscire sbaglio
ha suonato il campanello
c'è una roba terra ragazzi deve uscirne
1 andiamo così a mani nude a cazzotti
proprio che volava sardi e nero oddio
lunga e un gatto sarà stata la gallina
di primi nella nostra neanche ciao mamma
come stai mi scusi quella è casa mia
devo chiamare la polizia ma con quale
telefono fratello posso prendere lascia
che sta dietro
no perché c'è un ascia ti ricordo che ci
hai lasciati qua come un nero ecco
perché prendiamo questa bellissima ascia
non me la fa ovviamente non me la fa
prete ma certo posso prendere una di ste
cose per usarle come armi no non posso
prendere un cazzo andiamo lo stesso
giorno è una casa non ci sono
nascondigli qua come è possibile che sia
scappato c'è per caso un uomo brutto di
qui sotto letto no la chiama cielo
telefono è un iphone 6 ragazzi un iphone
6 plus frontone non fa non funziona per
certo in francia una cazzo di presa in
sta a casa cosa vuoi che funziona va beh
devo scappare in macchina immediatamente
la certo mai corri
ma via via abbiamo negato di merda via
cosa dov'è la mia macchina non è quella
la tua macchina benissimo malcelato la
macchina come se non bastasse una
nottata di merda rega e gatto morto non
prende il telefono mancio lato la
macchina fantastica ho qualcuno che mi
che ha voglia di spiegarmi dove è andato
il tizio perché ancora non ha capito lei
ci fossero i tuoi vicini ci hanno
ricevuto calorosamente così speriamo che
ci accetterei anche tu amico vero se per
accettarvi intendete che vi devo
prendere ad accettate in faccia
volentieri c'è il pacco di amato è
arrivato il corriere l'iphone 7 non è
l'iphone sette ragazzi non è l'iphone 7
però però non è ma comunque ragazzi la
testa del vicino è sempre più verde
questo da ricordare kat
c'è un tizio di forma donna di sopra di
guardare gli insidious c'è un tizio che
stati so però io non ho armi come cazzo
lo uccido mi scusi lei che cazzo se ne
sta nell'angolino stardoll c'è qualcuno
in cucina devono farci av gara c'era
scritto che devo nascondermi
nell'armadio ma non mi nascondo
nell'armadio perché non mi trova lui
vero che mitra porca [ __ ] quante
prodotto chiudi la porta stronza
perfetto
ciao qualche a buttarmi sono pagati in
mano c'era un uomo che camminava brutto
prima e se n'è andato via sono vivo
riuscito a scamparla credo e non lo so
ha lasciato un altro biglietto lega
perché ti stai nascondendo voglio
soltanto a giocare un po con te qual è
amico mio conosco un gioco bellissimo
che si chiama ci si ammazza nel modo più
bello vincere ecco cominciato
ne avete un po cagato il cazzo questi
biglietti non lo dico il vicino è una
sorpresa ti stanno aspettando vicino
all'albero ragazzi e ragazze il mio
compleanno quest'albero quanto ciao zio
ha trovato due cose che ti appartengono
sono la testa il braccio liri vuoi ai
due opzioni la prima inizierà a correre
per i campi cercando di arrivare in
città e la seconda è stare a casa e
continuare a giocare con noi c'è solo un
modo per sopravvivere devo correre in
città è esattamente quello che vogliono
che io faccia ragazzi non correrei così
facilmente in città ma si va a fan culo
facciamo ai dvd
[Applauso]
bravissimo minchia usain bolt che la
strada non ho mai proprio trafficata
vedo cazzo amico ci siamo trovato ed era
troppo tardi
le loro facce erano così brutti è la
madonna che bel trucco che ti metti
cache tracciata e rega ma cos'è ma non c
erano tre clown mascherati e mi hanno
riportato indietro nella casa ma cos'è
sta roba richiama quindi
vi prego e stato un sogno non penso
proprio
mi scusi signor mia zalli inclinò ma che
cazzo di fiumi prima di sviluppare i
videogame
niente canne ma zero proprio cioè non
devi neanche toccare non hai capito un
cazzo non è veramente finito così
ragazzino no no no no no non so neanche
descrivere sta roba vabbè vabbè ragazzi
concludo che l'episodio se il videogame
mi ha fatto cagare lasciato mi piace
come beccare like facili l'unica nota
positiva di tutta sta roba è stata la
gallina ricordatevi che se entrano i
ladri in casa avete un ascia vicino e
non toccatela perché non si sa mai mi
venga voglia di difenderli spero che vi
sia piaciuto questo servizio vissuto
assolutamente mi piace ampia fascia di
facebook e con il video totale inizia
nei servizi discreti e ci vediamo se ho
vinto è e attenti ai ladri in casa
perché botte proprio